american students are still reeling from
liberal coveted lockdowns that ruin
their education and the country's
biggest teachers union that pushed for
kids to be remote now has the audacity
to blame the mess on republicans randy
weingarten saying quote conservatives
are working consistently to undermine
educators in this country they're in the
same race as we are between fear and
hope aspiration and despair democracy
and autocracy and they're doing this
because our members worked so hard
during coven
but here's what actually was undermining
educators the billions of dollars in
covet cash that schools haven't used
senator tim scott pointing out in the
wall street journal op-ed how states
have only spent seven percent of the 122
billion dollars that got dished out all
right senator i'll go right to you they
spent seven percent that means 93
percent of that money is we're sitting
there doing nothing on behalf of the
kids of this country okay wait but let
me ask you one more question yes the
teachers have that money the unions have
the money the schools have the money and
we should take it back my bill would
take the money from the schools
sitting there doing nothing with it and
put it in the hands of the parents we
need to have parents in charge of
education if we are the party of parents
we are the party of the future and the
kids get a better education if the kids
get a better education our country is
going to be fantastic if we don't get
that right nothing else will matter and
i can't understand for the life of me
why the democrats refuse to empower
parents in education number one number
two why would you have
a hundred billion plus dollars sitting
on your books
and not using it for the learning loss
that happened during the pandemic not
using it for tutors not using it for
more charter schools why would you not
actually empower the entire system for
one purpose
the child
senator don't you usually though when
it's almost like a grant when i was a
d.a i would get grants i had to spend
that money use it use it show them yeah
use it or lose it absolutely why not
here that's because the way that the
money came out was not in our hands if
so the bottom line is that money still
sits on the on the balance sheets and
not being used whatsoever and the fact
of the matter is this one-time money
what we should do once again is
literally take the money back since it's
not being used and reappropriate it for
our parents if we give our parents the
resources
think about it the learning loss of our
kids over those two years could cost our
country
over two
trillion dollars in the lifetime earning
of our students
we can erase much of that by simply
putting the resources where they're
needed most in the hands by via
scholarships of our parents okay uh
senator all right senator hold on why
are your shoes off
[Laughter]
my first segment you guys were so good i
took my shoes off
i could think a little better i i had to
i had to
stop my game a little bit buddy so this
is how i did it take my shoes off he
feels at home good for you sir i like
that
jealous of my socks
all right greg you know what the the aft
and uh the national education
association two of the largest teachers
unions in the country received a copy of
guidance for return to in-person
learning before the centers for disease
control released it to the public now
doesn't that tell you that there was a
little bit of politicking going on
between the biden administration and
these unions which might be a reason why
they've got the money and they haven't
had to spend it
maybe i mean the fact is why would you
want to empower domestic terrorists yes
right i mean we have been told that
that's what parents are and now they
don't call them parents they call them
republicans right but that's just
another word what they were objecting to
most of all and it happened during covet
was scrutiny the ability of parents to
look carefully at the product that their
their children participate in and the
union resents that the
the union in a way is like a big fat
seal you don't want a popular tourist
wharf it doesn't have to get its food
people come up and just throw it in its
big fat mouth so it doesn't have to get
in shape it doesn't have to work it
doesn't have to be competent that is the
union union is a big fat flabby
disgusting seal that is doing nothing to
help children and i think that covet
enabled parents for wants to see this
and that when you see that that means
competition is around the corner and
this is a great lesson for liberals
progressives and democrats if you want
something good you have to have
something compete with it and when
there's no competition you end up with
an aoc who as nancy pelosi once said
could have been beaten by a cup of water
right and in this case with the with the
unions it's the same thing you guys suck
because you don't have competition
okay but what about the fact that they
did call parents domestic terrorists
parents who cared about once they had to
get involved their kids education
finding out that there was all this
progressive agenda and crt and all the
other nonsense i mean in a way it was a
blessing that we knew and started to
understand what was going on in school
it was a blessing and i will never feed
another seal for the rest of my life
just the big fat ones
let's say i send jesse junior to a
public school and his homeroom teacher
tells him he needs to come out of the
closet and then his history teacher
calls him a white supremacist
i will be jesse senior calling a
parent-teacher conference the next day
and i will be bringing maybe you my
lawyer to make sure that they know
what's appropriate and inappropriate to
talk about to my family
we're not undermining teachers they're
undermining my family and randy's out
there saying like the teachers worked so
hard they didn't work harder than the
firefighters the police officers all of
those essential workers
that had to actually show up to work
every day they zoomed in for almost two
years yeah and they have off on the
summer and they have off spring break
and christmas break they probably call
it winter break or winter solstice so
stop acting like they work that hard now
and then they held us hostage and then
basically said we weren't going to work
until you send us the money which they
didn't spend and probably embezzled
they also want a participation trophy
for not even participating
most workers you judge by their work
product right you judge by their results
but if you do that have they delivered
any good results no all the test scores
are going down permission to make an
analogy greg yes this would be like the
united auto workers union working like
you know every every other day and then
putting out cars that don't run and
break so then we buy the cars and
complain and they call us fascists
they're making bad cars they're selling
us a lemon and calling us fascists when
we complain perfect analogy children are
like broken cars
why is it that schools now are
short-staffed i mean you know jesse's
right that they they didn't have to
teach they they were either on zoom or
told the parents teach your own kids
we're not your babies
they had to i'm not here to defend the
unions but i will say this
i don't malign all police officers
because some don't do their job and some
don't go into schools when kids are
being shot in their classroom police
officers are amongst amongst the most
honored public servants in the land
they're teachers who are doing great
work their teachers give an example
there's a community schools program that
was this that was designed because
teachers in a certain school district i
won't i won't mention it said you know
what we have higher absenteeism rates on
mondays why is that they later learned
that many of the kids parents are unable
to wash the kids clothes over the
weekend aren't embarrassed if the kids
come to school in dirty clothes so what
the school decided to do they got more
washing machines and dryers and they
began washing the kids clothes i
interpreted something that aoc said i
don't agree with her on crime and
policing she's wrong but when she talks
about some of the social issues that
communities are facing this is one of
those issues any teacher that wants to
teach we ought to protect and venerate
those who don't want to teach should
leave the profession why are these we
shouldn't
because a lot of these teachers don't
feel supported a lot of these teachers
are finding other opportunities and a
lot of these teachers don't believe
their school systems i gave you that
example of the washing machine and dryer
machine as well i'm just trying to
answer the question
okay i guess that's why they don't have
enough washing machines hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else